-One!
-Two!
-Three!
-Four!
♪♪♪♪
♪♪ -Mmm, yeah ♪♪
♪♪ Mm-hmm ♪♪
♪♪ -Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ -I am special ♪♪
♪♪ -I'm so special ♪♪
♪♪ -I'm outstanding ♪♪
♪♪ -I can win ♪♪
♪♪ -So count me in ♪♪
♪♪ There is light and dark
and freckles ♪♪
♪♪ Lots of different
kinds of skin ♪♪
♪♪ Some folks like to sit
real quiet ♪♪
♪♪ Others like to
dance and spin ♪♪
♪♪ -Doesn't matter
where you come from ♪♪
♪♪ Doesn't matter
where you've been ♪♪
♪♪ -Everybody is important
♪♪ So count me in ♪♪
♪♪ -Oh, whoa, whoa ♪♪
♪♪ -Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ -I'm important ♪♪
♪♪ -I'm outstanding ♪♪
♪♪ -I can win ♪♪
♪♪ So count me in ♪♪
-Two!
-Three!
-One!
♪♪ -What I realize is
I love to learn ♪♪
♪♪ And the world is
full of surprises ♪♪
♪♪ When I open my eyes,
there's people ♪♪
♪♪ And beautiful colors
and shapes and sizes ♪♪
♪♪ From so many places,
so many faces ♪♪
♪♪ So many ways to embrace this
♪♪ But just in case
you missed it ♪♪
♪♪ Allow us to cover the basics
♪♪ -Some have straight hair
♪♪ Some have curly ♪♪
♪♪ -Doo, doo ♪♪
♪♪ -Some have hair
upon their chin ♪♪
♪♪ -Some have teeny
little smiles ♪♪
♪♪ -Others have
a great big grin ♪♪
♪♪ -Everybody's an original
♪♪ Even if you have a twin
♪♪ -Everybody is important
♪♪ So count me in ♪♪
♪♪ -Oh, come on, can you ♪♪
♪♪ -Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ Doo, doo ♪♪
♪♪ Count me in ♪♪
♪♪ I am special ♪♪
♪♪ I'm so special ♪♪
♪♪ I'm outstanding ♪♪
♪♪ I can win ♪♪
♪♪ So count me in ♪♪